last time this time on true fear I'm
sick bear with me
last time on true fear I talked about
the ghost hand in our photo
seriously look right there it's actually
there so if you haven't seen that
episode and want to hear more about that
hop on over the but on today's episode
independence day here in America the
land of the Americans and if you're part
of 32.1% of my audience that is not from
the USA then perhaps you've heard of the
1996 blockbuster starring Will Smith if
you haven't I highly recommend that you
give that one a watch but I can't say
the same for the sequel that came out 20
years later in fact the only
entertaining part of that movie going
experience was what went down in the
theater that even so being fans of the
original clawed gnome and I made plans
to go see this newly independent movie
it wasn't like right when the movie came
out or anything and I think we saw it
late on a weekday so there were some
people in the theater but it wasn't
packed there was also some remodeling
going on in that theater at the time so
I think that helped keep the crowds down
a bit and at this particular cinema they
have big recliners so it's not like
super high capacity anyways we were in
the second row from the back basically
in the middle of the screen there were
some couples scattered around the front
family who was in our row all the way to
the last guy in the row behind us all
the way in the right corner and a group
of people who are also in the back row
left the movie starts and about five or
ten minutes in the man sitting by
himself in the back right starts talking
in the Sun I don't remember what he was
talking about the only reason I didn't
say something right away was that
they're wonderful interesting 20 out in
the movie
this guy was slightly more entertainment
on screen I also figured that he'd be
off the phone soon before we got into
any of the board's well-being so I just
kind of tuned it out let's just say that
I'm glad that I did a couple minutes
later the guy who's still blabbering and
that's when I've decided enough is
enough I'm going to get up call this guy
out and tell him hey shut up we're
trying to watch the movie then literally
as I go to confront this guy I hear
someone from across the theater yell out
at him the first thing the phone guy
does is make his way across the road
over the people who yelled at him my
first impression was that they actually
knew each other like they were supposed
to meet here or something and the phone
guy was just going over to say hi then
even when they started yelling at each
other I was just thinking that it was
the type of thing where buddies are just
like giving each other a hard time
geez this sickness was giving me a hard
time what happened next was what started
to make me worry
first the yelling escalates and the guys
start pushing each other around then the
woman from the family in front of them
gets up and starts hollering at them
telling them knock it off stop it right
now
this causes the group that was fighting
in the back start getting into it with
her and her husband at this point the
commotion is completely drowning out the
movie I think would probably would have
spared fine and a brawl but the scary
part was when I turned and saw one of
the couples is one of us quickly get up
and speed out the theater because this
made me think that they had some reason
to be afraid
despite being pretty far away from where
the fight was taking place the first
thing that came into my head is that
they were trying to escape because
someone of their head of gun and after
what took place in Colorado in 2012 and
the increasing amount and taking place
in his country since the incident the
idea of something happening here was
actually pretty scared these people
seemed like pretty shady characters as
well and if someone is dumb enough to
start a fight movie theater who knows if
they're actually stupid enough to carry
a weapon between and I think what
started to make that possibility scary
as the situation continued to escalate
is the way they were acting which was
clearly outside of the social normal and
the way they were dressed which was
without any more explaining here they
were looking pretty thug and I'm not
saying that everyone who follows those
fashion trends is a dangerous criminal
or anything I think that makes about as
much sense as when people see me wearing
black and assume that means that I'm sad
or something but in the end it's just
something that contributed to us feeling
nervous about the situation and Claude
Nome would later tell me that he felt
the same way about it
however we paid like 14 bucks to get
into that movie and that's before you
even factored in the constant party so
we were going to stick that one out no
matter how bad he was no matter how
obnoxious the other party members no
matter how improves we were at risk of
becoming by entering this brawl and no
matter how likely it was that we would
be shot and killed before this movie let
out so we
so eventually the lady who is yelling at
them to stop and hold on can we just
pause for a second why is it that
whenever you see videos of a fight or
some kind of commotion in general
there's always some annoying lady
yelling out about how wrong this is how
disgusted she is how we all just need to
stop and think of the children it it
just seems that that lady is always
there
alright Timon so the lady takes her
family and storms out the cinema I'm not
sure if she threatened to report them to
the management or something as I
couldn't really make out all that was
being said but this is kind of what
triggered them to start moving the fight
towards the exit and they end up duking
it out down the aisle and so eventually
one of them made a run across the width
of the theater and out of our auditorium
so that was kind of a relief but at the
same time it was the end of that
entertainment or so
you would probably expect that after an
incident like that these hoodlums would
book it and get out of there before the
police showed up I'm not sure exactly
how long it passed before the three who
started the confrontation came marching
back into the theater not long after
that the original phone guy comes in and
stands at the exit just staring into the
auditorium
and that's where I was thinking this is
it this is where he comes back with his
48 caliber and shoots us all down he
even had his hand in his pocket and of
course he was blocking the only exits so
then he comes after the people who had
gotten into it with before and they
start going at it some more I don't
really have any idea like what made this
fight so personal that they still had
beef after things had pretty much
already cooled down eventually after a
scheme or people had fled the room they
chased the guy out of there again and
followed him out into the lobby I wish I
could have seen what happened out there
but also I didn't want to make it
obvious that I was watching and risk
getting myself too involved in it
so we were left with just a couple of
other moviegoers by the time this had
all died down we can only assume that
someone who had left had reported the
incident at some point what was
surprising to me is that nobody ever
came back to the theater except for one
employee who came with a flashlight and
collected something that was left behind
the three goons who had called the guy
out and his phone had left their jackets
so I guess the employee had to come
collect them before they left sir got
kicked out or whatever
nobody was questioned about the incident
and as far as I know the police never
showed up
we were not offered a refund but I'm not
sure if the same held true for the
people who left and possibly complaining
I was most surprised that the one family
who was sitting down the road from us
never returned because it seemed like
they would just go get the management
and come back they also left all of
their snacks and stuff behind some of
which were unopened it made me think
that something might have happened to
one of them out there or they honestly
were just really scared and fled the
entire place and never looked back we
enjoyed their unopened snacks at the end
as a consolation prize for having sat
through that movie but we never found
out the whole story of exactly what
happened that made the situation so
violent the scariest thing to me looking
back on it is it usually could have been
me who ended up in the site had those
other people not spoken before eise's
the other thing that was kind of
haunting was not knowing what took place
outside the auditorium or why none of
those other people ever returned
surprisingly enough this wasn't the only
scary occurrence that I've ever
experienced inside of a cinema so join
me next time on truth beer when I tell
the story what happened when I went to
go Stephen King's most underappreciated
movie 14:08 and additionally I also
posted a video a couple days ago and I
don't think it hit the sub boxes the
video about my series about the movie it
comes at night kind of funny that I did
this video about a disease movie and now
I'm super sick so I'm gonna link that
one to you guys in addition to the truth
your playlist remember to subscribe to
see these worlds from new Horrors every
week punch that death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
which for me right now it's looking time
to grow
[Music]